this video has been made possible thanks
to conflict of nations
in conflict of nations you will be in
control of the armed forces of one of
the world's leading nations manage the
economy diplomacy weapons research and
troop mobilization to lead your nation
to victory once you have an account you
can play the game on pc or mobile i know
it may seem strange for some people
talking about war video games when
witnessing a real war but wait make no
mistake conflict of nations is a video
game that like chess doesn't actually
hurt anyone and now the best of all you
can unlock your exclusive gift of 13 000
units of gold and get one month of
premium subscription for free by
clicking on the link in the description
this offer is only available for 30 days
so be quick and start mobilizing your
troops and planning your battle a little
more than 10 years ago we will watch
this over-acted footage with
astonishment
on the 17th of december 2011 the north
korean dictator kim jong-il died of a
heart attack he had ruled north korea
with an iron fist for 17 years from 1994
until 2011. during his reign the country
experienced the worst famine in its
history it was known as the arduous
march which left between half a million
and three and a half million people dead
from starvation in its wake according to
various estimates
[Music]
the fact is that after kim jong-il's
death his son kim jong-un inherited
power these days he is an
internationally recognized leader but at
the time his profile was hardly known
either inside or outside of north korea
the transition that lasted from december
2011 to april 2012 ended with a 29 year
old kim jong-un assuming full control of
the workers party of korea and the army
like his father kim jong-un's powers
became absolute
more than a decade has passed since then
a decade during which the hermit kingdom
of juche ideology has been under kim
jong-un's total control and has
regularly made headlines in the
mainstream international media i am sure
that most of you are already familiar
with many of the major events involving
this hermetic country over the past 10
years most notably its conversion into a
nuclear power but really how much has
north korea really changed during this
time how has the young kim managed to
consolidate his leadership in a regime
dominated by old glories what lies
behind the major decisions taken by the
great leader and perhaps the most
important question of all where is north
korea headed well we're going to answer
these questions and more in this video
so let's get started
[Music]
visualpolitik viewers we can define the
decade that kim jong-un has been at the
helm of north korea into four major
stages the first between 2012 and 2013
was the phase of consolidation of his
power the second between 2013 and 2017
would be called the byunjin phase and
i'll tell you all about that later the
third between 2018 and 2019 was the
diplomacy phase and the fourth from 2019
to the present day could well be known
as the covid phase well the first two
phases were a boost a key change in
north korean policy the end of the
so-called song goon doctrine
song goon was the north korean doctrine
that dominated all of previous dictator
kim jong-il's policies this doctrine was
based on the idea of army first and
according to it the north korean armed
forces were always a priority in other
words the use of available resources
should always be directed first and
foremost to the development of the
country's military capabilities the
result was the definitive boost to the
nuclear and ballistic program in 2013
however kim jong-un decided that this
policy needed to be relaxed and that
from then on the civilian development
would always have to be in step with
military development and so the bienjin
doctrine was born which literally means
parallel development under this new
policy the country's resources would no
longer be used only for the armed forces
but also to improve the living
conditions of north koreans at least for
those most loyal to the regime
[Music]
but why did kim jong-un decide to make
such a major change just one year after
seizing full and absolute power well
basically he did it because the economy
was in shambles after kim jong-il's rule
after the terrible famine the effort
made to develop weapons of mass
destruction and to the decline of its
old and inefficient industries the
country had simply run out of steam so
the current leader bet on this change
with the idea that the improvement in
general living conditions would help him
consolidate his power so the question is
did it work well the truth is that it
did although not for too long check it
out
the happy years of the new kim
[Music]
when kim jong-un came to power his youth
and inexperience in north korean power
circles led him to fear an internal coup
to rest power from him and that was
certainly a possibility that many
analysts took seriously after all
remember that kim was no ordinary north
korean but a guy who had studied in
switzerland and was an nba fan the risk
was there this hypothetical attack could
come from two fronts from the army by
some of the most traditionalist old
glories of the regime or from the party
from the hand of a leader who wanted to
reform the system as to some extent had
happened in china with deng xiaoping let
me ask you a question what do dictators
usually do when they take very seriously
the possibility of a coup d'etat to oust
them from power three two one exactly
implant a regime of terror act quickly
and carry out a bunch of purges as soon
as possible come on the tyrant must come
first well guess what that's exactly
what the north korean leader did the
young dictator wanted to prove that he
was not weak just because he was young
and of course if anything has become
clear over the years it's that this guy
has a steady hand i'm sure you all
remember the assassination of his own
brother kim jong-nam in february 2017 at
the kuala lumpur airport when two women
approached him from behind and poisoned
him
[Music]
earlier in late 2013 kim jong-un ordered
a much more important execution for
political purposes that of his uncle
jiangsung fake a senior regime official
who was shot after being accused of
factionalism corruption drugs and
gambling this was one of the highest
level purges since the 1950s and the
question is why did he kill him well the
truth is that it is suspected that this
high-ranking official was opposed to the
new policies that kim jong-un wanted to
implement
[Music]
what's more in this case the young
dictator made sure that absolutely the
whole country and the whole world knew
about this game changer it was something
like a warning weak who says i'm weak
look for your own sake don't test me or
you'll be next
north korea's kim jong-un purges his
uncle in spectacular public fashion the
guardian and the fact is that these
kinds of purges had their effect since
then kim's leadership has not been
called into question again at least as
far as is known and thanks to that he
was able to implement the new policy
that the new leader wanted to turn into
his major standard the pyongjin doctrine
under this new beyond jin or parallel
development policy kim promised his
people that they would never again have
to tighten their belts with this new
model kim wanted to push for
chinese-style economic reform that is
without political openness for example
it recognized private markets and
enacted a law that gave more autonomy to
public enterprises the idea was to favor
a certain degree of entrepreneurship
productive efficiency and competition
without private ownership and that's not
all it also created around 20 economic
development zones and a joint ventures
law in an attempt to attract foreign
capital especially chinese capital
of course we're talking about a country
where state planning is practically
omnipresent so these special economic
zones were divided into agricultural
industrial and tourist zones among other
specialties now the question we can ask
ourselves is did all these reforms serve
to improve the country's economic
situation
[Music]
well the truth is that it seems that
they did it is estimated that in 2016
the north korean economy had its best
year since 1989 just before the collapse
of the soviet union not that 1989 was
anything to throw a parade for we are
talking about an estimated economic
growth of approximately 3.9 percent
according to calculations by the central
bank of south korea these calculations
are based on intelligence reports
satellite analysis and the evolution of
exports and imports among other
indicators be that as it may the point
is that there were more cars on the road
somewhat higher levels of consumption in
the big cities and a certain boom in the
construction sector in fact here on
visualpolitik we have a whole video
dedicated to north korea's big projects
i'll leave a link in the description and
let's see it's not that the country was
going like gangbusters far from it but
by north korean standards things did
start to improve and visual politic
viewers the changes were not limited to
the economic sphere in the political
field there were also new developments
the young kim reformed the power
structure within the states so that the
army was no longer the most powerful
institution in the country but the party
that is under kim jong-un's command
civilian positions have prevailed over
military ones
we are talking about north korea one of
the most militarized countries in the
world so in spite of everything the
juche leader took advantage of the
relative economic bonanza to finish
developing the nuclear and ballistic
weapons program in fact north korea
conducted two nuclear tests in 2016 and
2017 allegedly including the hydrogen
bomb numerous intercontinental ballistic
missile tests were also carried out some
of which even flew over japan
august 2017 missile passing japan wakes
to ominous warning about north korean
launch sirens blared out trains stopped
and residents took cover as missile
fired by north korea soared over
japanese territory for two minutes the
guardian this was obviously a big deal
north korean missiles flying over japan
and setting off anti-missile alarms in
one of the west's main allies the
response it was clear was not going to
be long in coming
[Music]
and yes it was these tests both nuclear
and ballistic that slammed the door on
the mirage of progress and openness that
kim jong-un's reforms seem to have set
in motion
september 2017 security council imposes
fresh sanctions on democratic people's
republic of korea including bans on
natural gas sales work authorization for
its nationals un press at that time the
international community imposed the
toughest sanctions on the country to
date including a ban on gas sales and
severe limitations on oil sales in
addition the granting of work permits to
north koreans was also banned so that
many of the state-owned companies that
operated abroad to earn foreign currency
had to close down this of course ended
an important source of financing for the
regime
as you can imagine this changed
everything the good run came to an end
and the north korean economy went back
into a hard recession in just two years
north korea's international trade is
estimated to have plummeted 57
from around 6.5 billion dollars to
around 2.8 billion and so kim's plan
went straight into the trash yes the
dominant doctrine had changed but what
did not change were the priorities the
survival of the regime above all else
including of course the hopes for a
better standard of living of the north
korean population so now the question is
what did kim do after such a failure
what did this decrepit regime come up
with to get out of the hole well pay
close attention because i am sure many
of you will soon have a clearer picture
of what is going on in north korea
[Applause]
[Music]
false diplomacy
[Music]
in 2017 the stars aligned for kim
jong-un on the one hand there was donald
trump as president of the united states
an uncommon leader with a strong
populist character who was happy to sit
down for a chat with any tyrant even the
leader of the worst dictatorship on
earth on the other hand the now former
south korean president moon jae-in a
disciple of the sunshine policy the
policy of openness towards north korea
in the late 1990s had just come to power
what better opportunity for kim jong-un
than to take advantage of such a
scenario and present himself as a guy
willing to negotiate with an apparent
willingness to compromise even if it
meant denuclearizing north korea this is
an old north korean trick by the way
after all what democratic leader would
not want to sell a political success as
great as achieving a definitive peace
treaty for the korean war or the glory
of securing the denuclearization of the
korean peninsula the idea was too
tempting for all parties
[Music]
the north korean regime realized that
the u.n sanctions were causing more
havoc than they had calculated so they
needed the sanctions to be ease no
matter what and the only way to achieve
this was to improve relations with
washington that meant stopping all of
the tests and the constant military
provocations it was time for diplomacy
the fake diplomacy
this type of diplomacy consisted of
offering something that they really knew
they were not going to deliver in order
to achieve what the regime needed
remember what kim said about north
koreans not having to tighten their
belts again well just that and so
between 2018 and 2019 we witnessed two
historic images on the one hand a south
korean president returned to pyongyang
after 11 years and on the other hand a
north korean dictator met twice and
shook hands with the president of the
united states himself something that had
never happened before these were truly
strange images meetings that of course
did not take long to blow up
the latest reproachment between north
korea the united states and south korea
took place in 2019 in the vietnamese
city of hanoi this summit was a real
fiasco after almost two years of
charades kim still had not achieved his
real goal to have sanctions against
north korea lifted and of course the
charade without any result was already
dragging on so long that it was
beginning to hurt kim's image the north
korean leader was showing an uncommon
image of weakness in the face of his own
regime let's just say that he had shaken
hands with his arch enemy to achieve
absolutely nothing
as a result the hanoi summit ended
prematurely and according to the united
states these were the reasons
it was all about the sanctions basically
they wanted the sanctions lifted in
their entirety and we couldn't do that
president donald trump
the dilemma that we were confronted with
is the north koreans at this point are
unwilling to impose a complete freeze on
their weapons of mass destruction
programmes so to give many many billions
of dollars in sanctions relief would in
effect put us in position of subsidizing
the ongoing development of weapons of
mass destruction in north korea senior
u.s state department official oh kim kim
they saw your play it was the snake that
bites its own tail north korea demanded
an end to sanctions before making any
gestures and the united states demanded
that north korea dismantle its nuclear
and ballistic program before lifting
anything it was clear that any agreement
was impossible so everything fell apart
and north korea's economic crisis
continued we have now come all the way
to 2019 and this is what happened next
listen up
kovid's final nail in the world's most
hermetic country
2019 was also a bad year for the kim
jong-un regime first the sanctions were
still in place and it was clear that
they were not going away so the north
korean leader no longer had any
incentive to continue to show a friendly
face for what so do you know what he did
well yes he went back to the policy of
reinforcing the armed forces at all
costs especially in terms of strategic
armaments he did it perhaps to present
himself once again as a tough and strong
guy to the regime's own top brass or
perhaps to make up for his political
failure or perhaps to remind the world
that kim jong-un was not some affable
good-natured guy be that as it may this
meant the end of the beyond jin doctrine
and a return to the old policies
in this way kim largely re-established
the usual economic system and returned
in his speeches to the importance of
self-sufficiency which basically means a
return to the hard and strict autarky
that had been so characteristic of north
korea and in terms of foreign policy kim
jong-un progressively froze all the
dialogues that had been opened in the
previous phase the most dramatic
expression of this was to blow up the k
song into korean liaison office in june
2020
and of course don't forget that late
2019 early 2020 was when the sars
coronavirus ii pandemic was set in
motion a pandemic which as we all know
originated in china and which caused the
regime to close down again practically
from the outset not even allowing trade
with china except for essential goods so
the north korean economy once again went
back into recession and given the
circumstances in this country what is
lost is not regained with kovite 19
north korea has returned to a state of
almost total isolation to a state of
absolute autarky and extreme crisis
something very similar or even worse
than what kim jong-un found when he
ascended to the throne in 2011.
and that is not all to make matters
worse the lack of water infrastructure
and heavy rains have caused uncontrolled
flooding at some times of the year and
extreme droughts at others which is once
again causing a food crisis the real
magnitude of which is unknown
july 2022 north korean towns along the
border with china were flooded this week
after heavy rain threatening to
exacerbate an already critical food and
economic situation in the country
reuters
with cross-border trade still severely
constrained because of covet 19 help
from abroad will be limited the
economist so could we be talking about a
lost decade in north korea well no the
truth is that this is not the case on
the one hand kim jong-un has achieved
his goal of shoring up his power and
giving continuity to the kim dynasty
which by the way did not seem to be an
easy task on the other hand the years of
relative economic prosperity have left
significant urban developments in
pyongyang samjon and wan-san which have
brought new housing to thousands of
north koreans as well as hotels
hospitals and improvements in several
airports among other things but the
situation that has developed over the
past two years could even put kim
jong-un's leadership at risk in any case
what seems clear is that north korea's
near future is lacking any level of
prosperity
kim will have a long 2023 to decide what
course he wants for north korea in the
post-covered era a return to the policy
of parallel development or a
continuation of the radical militaristic
autarky of the song and doctrine as
expected on visualpolitik we will be
keeping a close eye on all the events
that unfold in the hermit kingdom but
now at this point it's your turn do you
think kim jong-un's leadership is
guaranteed until his own passing away
what path do you think north korea will
take in the post-covered era do you
think there is any possibility of
internal rebellion against kim because
of the crisis either from the regime
elites or from the people leave us your
thoughts below in the comments and if
you liked this video go ahead give it a
like and subscribe to our channel also
hitting that little bell icon so you
don't miss any news remember that if you
want to feel like sun tzu and speculate
on military strategies the free online
pvp strategy game conflict of nations is
worth checking out click on the link in
the description to get your unique
starter pack but remember that the offer
is only available for 30 days all the
best see you next time
[Music]